y a pas eu de mobilisation pendant cette
semaine la mobilisation entre les deux
tours à les rares à les rarissimes
si elle se produit ce ne peut être que
localement alors l'exemple du
département des yvelines le monde et
vient nous rappeler de manière très
opportune au demeurant que ce scrutin
est censé être un scrutin local mais son
caractère national sa nationalisation
atteint un point probablement qu'il n'a
jamais atteint depuis 1971 les scrutins
locaux sont traditionnellement
interprété comme étant des scrutins
intermédiaires on parle de cela aux
états unis comme les midterm élections
et c'est ce qu'on fait aussi en france
depuis 1971 on a plutôt tendance à le
faire mais jamais depuis 40 ans depuis
plus de 40 ans le scrutin n'avait
n'avait ne s'était vu attribuer une
dimension aussi fortement nationale
parce que vous avez senti dans
l'entre-deux-tours une mobilisation sur
eux sur le terrain est ce que vous
pensez que c'est déjà joué ou non et que
la droite va l'emporter ce soir on va
écouter mathématiquement faut que guy
maddin face puis 80% dans une
triangulaire donc je suis moi je veux
prendre des paris grave problème je
viens j'ai un peu d'argent l'a remplacé
par contre effectivement il ya trois ans
il ya il ya du suspense dans savoir
est-ce qu effectivement il y aura du
changement de maire est un changement à
voisin moteur par contre effectivement
la gauche ne viendra de sièges ont
effectivement mathématiquement le
résultat des élections
on connaît déjà un certain temps qui est
23 25 pour la droite à saint quentin
ville comme ça a été 22 20 pendant 16
ans où j'étais et finement président
voyez donc comme combien vous
l'expliquer ça mais parce qu'on a fait
beaucoup de cinéma j'irai sur les
nouvelles élections les nouvelles lois
ne changent rien et dans les élections
municipales il ya eu aucun moment j'ai
vu apparaître 50 alvin un projet pour
51,8
tous les maires ont été réélus au
premier tour très largement qu'ils
soient de gauche ou de droite
sauf dans deux villes où le maire n'a
pas pu faire l'union dans sa propre
famille c'est le cas c'est le droit à
tracer un voisin c'était déjà le cas
déjà
la lumière de la foi dernier un voisin
c'est ça qui va deux autres et se
permettait de me mettre deux choses
importantes
le front national à saint-quentin mine
quand on voit la vague soi-disant bleu
marine ou noire de la france cette vague
là elle n'est pas sur 50 ans les mines
déjà le front national pu faire des
disques dans deux seules communes sur
les sept communes de l'agglomération et
ils ont pas fait plus de 10% vous
parliez tout à l'heure de des
thématiques et avait été retenu dans
cette campagne notamment le jour du
pouvoir ça ce sont des ces conjectures
elle se conjoncturel c'est politique
mais il y avait il ya eu surtout cette
élection était un référendum sur un
thème précis de notre de notre ville qui
fait peur de ville qui est telle que la
ville voilà ça a été un référendum ce
référendum voilà on l'a gagné entre
guillemets donc il ya une forte
participation sur ce sur ce sujet là et
puis il ya aussi le fait que en effet le
renouveau a beaucoup a beaucoup joué à
beaucoup mobilisé les artistes pour
cette élection
on a vécu cette participation sur la
ville de montigny de manille par dont 66
ans est en hausse par rapport à 2008 ont
prises donc on a senti et une joie
d'ailleurs à magny les hameaux de sentir
une progression de participation sa
marque l'intérêt des habitants de magny
les hameaux pour leur commune
sachant que ce qu'on a présenté ce dont
on a parlé c'est uniquement notre
territoire magny les hameaux
et c'est là dessus que les habitants ont
plus en plus s'investir discuter se
mobiliser et et on voit que quand on
parle de choses vraies de réalité aux
habitants et aux citoyens de manière
générale finalement ils se mobilisent et
on voit les résultats de ce premier tour
de cet unique thoiras à magny les
hameaux justement à coignières henry
pailleux participation près de 51 à 57
pour 61,57 leurs champs pour être précis
61%
oui bah écoutez
à coignières sûr mais à part 1983 où il
y avait plus de 70 % de votants depuis
on est toujours à 61 62 % vous savez une
élection municipale de tout le monde le
sait c'est avant tout une élection
locale
même si le national peut peser sur le
résultat des élections et à coignières
moi depuis que je suis à quoi dire en 77
je me suis totalement identifié je
dirais à la ville de coignières
d'ailleurs bécaud derrière ne s'y
trompent pas et cette fois ci si j'ai
fait un score alors que je vais toujours
élu avec plus de 65% même aux contres
taxe était élue elle 72% dans une ville
qui vote à gauche à 60% élections
politiques
eh bien je pense que les coréens me font
confiance et continuent à me faire
confiance